[Music]
sophie are you ready to begin
take me back
where were you before
and before that
and before that
can you keep going
[Music]
do you know what it feels like
to not remember anything
everyone keeps telling me who they think
i am it's a fresh start but if my life
was so perfect why did i try to end it
[Music]
sophie it's time to move forward but i
need to know what really happened we do
know no we think we know based on what
we think happened
what if i didn't jump
was there anything unusual about that
day
you were saying all kinds of crazy
things a man pushed you from the boat
your id said one name and you kept
consisting it was something else
people with perfect lives don't usually
jump off of fairies
daily accident your husband's alibi is a
lie
if you're starting to remember some
things that must be really scary
sometimes it's hard not knowing you're
in secrets
we can't just pretend we're new people
[Music]
we're that the past doesn't exist
you really don't remember dude your
husband's not really thinking
why did you lie she's starting to ask
questions i can't answer maybe i was
wrong about everything
sophie what's going on
just
putting the pieces together
[Music]
you